I don't think that men need to not cry
it's they just don't think you need to
cry at every single thing that bothers
you I don't think you need to cry
because someone called you a name this
is when men often cry mug clubs for
closers I want to kind of warn people
before usually these closing segments
are our I guess uplifting or helpful
it was branded by some fans crowd or
closes and so now we use that on YouTube
thank you for the idea but I want to
warn anyone there who is having a good
time I don't want to ruin your day this
one is a little bit sad hopefully
helpful so you know if you need to grab
some time or come back to this later 3 -
there you go spoiler alert I know I
talked about this on social media this
week that hopper of course who you know
and hopper he's been on the show quite a
bit was diagnosed with cancer lymphoma
cancer so it's been a very hard week for
us it is you know listen here's the
thing I I've debated going I've gone
back and forth whether I should even
talk about this because we don't know he
could live a longer time you know he's a
10 year old dog and he may not depends
on how he responds to treatment depends
on how aggressive it is and it was a
real roller coaster ride because we got
this on Friday this news and then we
went to the oncologist and they said hey
we actually don't think that's what it
is and so we felt so good like a weight
was lifted and then we found out
yesterday that that is what it was and
they said maybe it's not the fast-moving
cancer and it is the fast-moving
lymphoma cancer and I know as people
it's always a cop-out where people try
to talk about it I just want to talk
about things so people don't feel alone
but I do know with millions of listeners
out there people are tuning and they're
probably people going through a similar
situation I want to be clear about
something here I know that a man whom
the hardest thing they've ever
experienced is their dog with cancer has
lived a charmed life it's not lost on me
okay I want to make sure they understand
that I'm not equivocating losing a dog
by the way he may not we don't
what's gonna happen we don't know how
long he's going to be here but I did
feel that since he's been an active part
of the show that I owed it to you to
talk about this now and when it does
happen when we he's not with us anyone
we're not gonna do another clothing
segment on this I wanted to talk about
this now so that you didn't feel lied to
because I know that Hopper up there is
twenty thirty thousand followers on
Twitter we don't even know who runs at
accounting by the way whoever runs the
hopper accounts out there obviously when
when the final chapter is written and
appreciate if you you just kind of close
it down because I don't don't want to
have to to look at that um so I
understand that someone who's been
through something like this thing it's
the hardest thing that they've they've
been through they've lived a very
charmed life this has absolutely been
the hardest thing that I've ever
experienced and I try to be honest as
honest as I can with you these last two
years have been some of the hardest in
my life and this is the hardest thing
I've been through I've lost relatives
I've lost friends I've had friends who
were taken too young I know this doesn't
compare to to losing children but my dad
had melanoma and I know it doesn't mean
that I don't love my father more it
doesn't mean that I understand the value
of human life is greater than a dog
that's not it
but hopper is outside of my wife the
living being on this earth that I gave
more of myself to than any other person
on this planet
my best friend is dying and there's no
more honest way to express it I don't
know I know this this is the kind of you
know what good I don't care someone will
take that and turn it into a meme up
see I don't you know I'll walk away from
this before I ever actually have to feel
ashamed of the fact that I'm emotional
over the emotional over losing a good
friend and I know it'll be used against
me I know that'll turn into a meme
whatever and I've talked about this I
don't think that men need to not cry I
just don't think you need to cry at
every single thing that bothers you I
don't think you need to cry because
someone called you a name this is when
men often cry let me kind of give you
some information on Harper because you
see him but you don't you don't really
know the whole story I prayed I prayed
for opera I really did
my whole life and he's really been a
gift in my life and in my family's life
and he's been the best gift and I poured
so much myself I never had a dog growing
up and I wanted one I begged that
pleaded for one I had all the dog books
I watched the dog shows on TV I knew
every breed I knew all the training
methods but I couldn't have one because
I was raised in an apartment and by the
way this is gonna come back to something
that's hopefully helpful for people out
there so you don't just nishan it off
because it's sad there's a purpose to
this and I learned a lot this week
not that cheesy this dog taught me more
about it's almost like this dog was
rescuing me it's not that but I did
learn a lot this week I couldn't have a
talk when I grew up because I was raised
in an apartment little three-bedroom on
Reed Street in the South Shore of
Montreal you can run a search on that
right now and see the silver spoon with
which I was raised
once I've been married for a couple of
years I decided that I was going to
fulfill a dream and see at this point in
time I should clarify parted ways with
Fox News I'd sold some script rights I
was getting burnt out with stand-up I
was in Western Michigan kind of
floundering I was depressed I talked I'm
gonna grab some water here real quick so
those were listening to rest really
sorry it's it's just my mouth was dry it
was drier than usual keep him real man
people say they've never known actually
keeping it real I'd be crying if they
were um I was oppressed and I've talked
about this before my wife didn't fully
know how depressed I was because I'd be
up before her in the morning and I'd be
off to the gym before she left for work
and after the gym I didn't know where I
was headed in my life hadn't oars had I
just knew that I had to keep moving but
I decided it was the right time to
fulfill a lifelong dream I wanted my
whole life I wanted to have a dog again
it's I know it sounds silly but when
you're a kid and all you want is a dog
and you cannot have a dog it's a big
deal so around Christmas time five five
years ago six years ago I start looking
on Petfinder
and actually became a volunteer at a
local non-kill shelter which required a
certain level of training to even begin
with had the books I watched the
training videos and I was gonna be the
best dog owner ever hopper popped up on
Petfinder
and I remember the lady bring him to her
and he was so nuts that first of
momentum with energy because he'd been
in a crate for so long
and by the way I want to make sure no
one thinks that this no she was not
abusing the dog she ran a rescue with
her best friend and she lost her best
friend to cancer no like it's been a
crappy 2019 one of my wife's best
friends just got diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer and obviously no it's
just it's been a rough a few months but
I'm still grateful it's a day above
ground and there people have it a whole
lot worse so people out there who have
it worse don't think that I'm comparing
my plight to yours it's lady who ran the
shelter anyway that's what I was talking
about she she had a friend who ran it
with her and not a shelter a rescue they
ran out of their house but her friend
died cancer and so she was overwhelmed
and she had to create a lot of the dogs
because not all dogs get along and
hopper had always been a people dog he's
a super easy dog and you know this oh
yeah as long as he's around his people
the reason he's not in here now by the
way you know he's not dead people who
were like where's hot place it's just
because there are other people around
right now he'd rather be in the room
where the most amount of people are but
he doesn't do well in a crate so he came
in the house he was buzzing around like
crazy
he immediately rolled over put his paw
on me and you know licked my face but my
wife and I remember we decided that we
weren't just going to take the dog in
our first meeting we were going to talk
about it we were going to be disciplined
which the remember the rescue lady
seemed really surprised and I felt bad
because she made a decent trip out to us
it was little ways and she shouldn't
have been so surprised at that point
she's effectively bringing a fat three
legged balding alopecia dog with Lyme
disease as you know we'll take it but he
wasn't always the hopper that you see
today but I told her we'd give her an
answer the following day like I said
this was hopefully gonna tie back in
this is me taking time for me here
but we really had already decided the
next day we drove out we meet her we
meet this lady between our place in her
place took him in her old Explorer was
it the tourists I don't know he ripped
the steering wheel off the tourists when
we took him to the outdoor shooting
range we parked a mile away and he still
heard he took the steering wheel off of
our Taurus
I remember she told us that first night
she told us that we had to create him
that number how much she wailed him and
how much he complained that just stick
it through you got to put him in the
crate well that night he hold this I
mean his dog howled I came down the next
morning to find the crate was it looked
like the
shark cage and jaws after it been torn
apart by the by the real shark they
inserted documentary film footage in
that it's broken down he thrown up he
pooped in there and my wife and I were
actually on our way to the Rite Aid for
ear plugs to prepare for the next night
because when we got to stick this
through when we came back we realized
that we hadn't crated him but he was
just sleeping his bet fine maybe he
doesn't need it so we went to church
came back was in his bed didn't so much
as nibble a shoelace I went to go see
Captain America I don't member which one
it was at that point I came back same
and we've never really had a problem
with him ever since we haven't had to
create him he got into the trash every
now and then that's because my wife left
to slim jim on the top of the trash at
one point and it was open and so he just
thought oh the trash is a place I go for
James if it's on the top they just pull
it Costanza but it is funny because when
I heard what the doctor said I really
could remember it's one of those things
people say your life flashes before your
eyes but when you're about to lose
something really important everything
that's important about that person that
thing floods every part of your brain
things that I didn't even know were in
there from how he's just sleeping on my
the bed next to my desk and our dan back
when we did the show and it was in a den
he was right next to my desk every
single day used to Ram his head if the
door was closed just boom oh you'd hear
him crying I remembered serving him
sardines on the old front porch and
trying to eat them myself and almost
throwing up I remember teaching this to
sit to stay and everything them to run
out by the old East Grand Rapids the
East Grand Rapids High School track
taking it up north for the first time
and particularly I remember that second
night after the first night with the
crate I remember him just falling asleep
and my wife's arms in the futon like
he'd known her his whole life and he's
done it ever ever since every single
night and I had to be in a schedule
proper I had to live for something else
who was completely dependent on me and
that's why I think this is so hard is he
can't tell us you know that he's in pain
that's what's so hard you have to make a
decision out of wanting to avoid cruelty
and sometimes you have to make a
decision that is to end the life of
someone or something you care so much
about
but at this point I remember I I it gave
me a purpose it made me more of an adult
and hopper they me happy he makes me
really happy and sometimes in life you
can pitch your flashpoint moments that
cut deeper than you've ever felt in your
life in that moment those words are
burned into your memory edge to the
walls of your soul forever and when we
found the news I my wife tearing up and
she said she said I just wanted to
bottle everything up about hopper there
is and just carry it she said this just
wanted to bottle up everything that was
about hopper and just carry it with her
forever that's exactly how I feel and I
feel terrible that there's nothing I can
do to help my wife to that something is
terrible they talk about toxic
masculinity listen it doesn't come from
having to prove myself
it comes from loving my wife from trying
to provide for my wife from wanting to
burden that painted my wife because
we're called to do that as men as
Christians as believers and God yet
believers in Christ it's really painful
not just losing your best friend but
knowing how much pain your wife is in
and there's nothing you can do some
people get some great gifts in their
lives and hopper really was the best
gift I can I can talk about this a
little bit you everyone always says
their dog is special and I'm sure that's
true to an extent but believe me when I
say that Hopper really is especially he
changed lives and I see people like I
miss my dog and it's just a dog that's
you know crapping around the house and
they they have no relationship with
there's no peace in the house
no hopper was the change lives I don't
just mean in the sense that oh he
changed our lives or he brought lover to
the house he changed people's lives ask
anyone on the team he's probably changed
a lot of your lives
ask anyone who's come to visit people
who don't even like dogs loved hopper my
aunt who was terrified of dogs loved
hopper wanted to get a dog because of
hopper kids who were terrified of dogs
loved hopper didn't he didn't always
love them back that's the one thing
hopper with the kids who were
rambunctious whacking him he didn't have
he would walk away but if he walked away
and you followed him you'd see the growl
you saw the hodgetwins good
on this show freak when I introduced in
the hopper one of the funny things ever
say about passed out in the show
laughing they were terrified what you
didn't see was the next time they came
over to my house and Hopper was there
they were sitting and petting her but
this is even just his last time because
he was such a peaceful dog and he's by
the way shouldn't say he was he is such
a calm dog and such a loving dog that he
would change people's hearts in views on
dogs he had a gift genuinely of melting
away fear and they wanted to make him a
therapy dog until we found out that he
didn't like sunglasses if you were
wearing sunglasses he might mess you up
so thank God we didn't make him a
therapy dog but that's why I'm going
through this in it being the most
painful thing I've experienced I'm
ashamed to say that at one point I
actually just thought when when this was
just happening and you know was its
blinding pain the worst part was not
knowing what was happening right that's
what sometimes worse is the anticipation
than what actually happens not knowing
the answer where was the aggressive
cancer or there was a slow-moving cancer
at one point I actually just thought of
wanting to have Betty our new puppy
adopted not because I don't love Betty
but because I thought I just could never
go through this again I really thought
I'll do anything to avoid this kind of
pain again at all costs and then I
realized how stupid and ungrateful I was
I probably never felt more ashamed of
myself in my life that I was taking a
gift that I'd prayed for my whole life
all my channel said spinning on it
why because I didn't get to keep it
forever because as much as it hurts I've
gained so much more and I really hope
that for a three-legged dog with
alopecia and Lyme disease he would say
that I hope that I gave enough and I
realize that I felt that way before not
just about hopper I felt that way with
this show where things got so hard that
I wanted to throw it all away anything
to avoid the hell that I was going
through at that point ever again but
I've gained so much more you have given
me so much more in the same way I can
only hope that I've given enough so to
take away tonight and it's a cliche I
know but sometimes the tale as old as
time is that way for a simple reason and
that's because it's true I've talked
about it before is nothing new but
genuinely be grateful
and something else too I noticed we were
sometimes you're really praying and
begging for something more then you'll
have gratitude for when you actually get
what you you asked for because when we
were praying please please we just want
this to be aggressive cancer and then
they told us it probably wasn't we said
well we really really need to be
thankful here now then that was taken
away from us because it turned out that
it was they went back and forth get your
facts straight svet know there couldn't
that say they couldn't no he's a weird
dog he's tough to examine but sometimes
you pray for miracles and then don't
believe that they'll happen and I also
noticed that pain doesn't we used to say
misery loves company I don't think it's
that so much as pain doesn't love to be
alone we worked the vet and when we got
that good news at the oncologist I
remember there was a lady there with her
dog Leah who had mesothelioma and wasn't
doing so well and we told her about
hopper and we went in and that was at
the point when they gave us better news
and we came out and she said yeah what
did she seemed upset what news did you
get and we could tell she was upset and
we said yeah you know it's it's not good
we just received great news but we
realized that she would feel more alone
if we said yeah great news and her dog
was probably not going to make it with
mess with you know what really rough was
pretty far along because pain just
doesn't want to be alone and that's why
I'm sure I try to be as transparent as
possible by the way sharing something
for the sake of sharing a Jordan
Peterson Setauket doesn't help anybody
if it's not something good a lot of
people just share sin a lot of people
share their faults and don't offer a
solution well I just don't want you to
feel alone and so they talk about mental
health issues or drugs will haunt you
have a solution to it otherwise you're
not helping but sharing paying the kind
of pain that everyone goes through it
really does help people knowing that
they're not alone but if we're gonna to
have one takeaway this week and now I'm
just sort of circling the runway I guess
it really is simple be grateful if
you've got a gift appreciate it share it
because most gifts nearly all gifts
aren't forever and just because it's not
forever or just because at some point it
may hurt it doesn't mean that it's not a
gift and you don't have the right to
throw it all away okay there if you like
this video this is the part where
usually tell you to subscribe but I
can't do it anymore I'm gonna tell you
to subscribe and then YouTube is going
to decide that we can't reach you even
though you subscribe to this channel and
then I'll say hit the notification bell
and then the notification Bell won't
even be there anymore I don't know what
to say more than likely you'll find my
face in a milk carton but do what you
can to stop it it's just it's just it
probably won't do much